there's something sinister foot a
natural doctrine this turn-based
strategy game is coming to all three
Sony platforms later this summer and
doesn't look too scary on the surface
wizards and goblins square off against
each other casting fireballs and
swinging clubs while Knights cower
behind their shields like any wise
fighter would no one would have any
reason to be scared what they well
that's where the beauty of a tactical
battle hides because it's only after you
even broiled yourself in a bitter
showdown they realize how your lacks
attitude cost you strategy games hold a
special place in my heart unlike
traditional role playing games where
stories and characters push me onward
it's the joy of outsmarting an opponent
that's so satisfying here positioning is
key in natural doctrine rush for too
quickly you may put yourself in a poor
position but cowardly staying far away
limits how far you can move compare your
mage to the Queen and chess something
like a Red Mage it's the linchpin for
success if you're aggressive you could
pick off some of your enemies before
they know what's happening but the match
may be over quickly if your mage false I
only watch two representatives from NIS
square often Vita ad hoc play and could
feel the tension as things came to a
head one player was aggressive early and
left himself open because of his
recklessness natural doctrine has a
linking system that's super important
group your allies together and you get
benefits such as getting to juggle your
turn order so if you don't link you
better kill quickly because you're
leaving yourself vulnerable single and
multiplayer are completely separate
entities so if you just want to
challenge your friend you can ignore the
campaign completely the game plays out
like a card collecting game you choose
your team from a deck of characters and
unlock new cars you go along and here's
some good news there aren't any
microtransactions so everyone has to
work to build the best deck possible
natural doctrine has one interesting
feature that we haven't seen before you
can challenge friends across all three
systems so if you're playing on Vita
like I will tap your ps3 or ps4 friends
or still tethered to a television NIS
understands what they have with natural
doctor this won't be a massive
phenomenal success
there's a hungry audience of people
craving hardcore strategy games and this
looks to satisfy their cravings so keep
your eyes on this hidden gem
you